[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to the data
science hangout it's so nice to see
everybody again i'd love to hear what
everybody was up to all july
but it was so awesome to be able to meet
so many of you at the our studio
conference last week too
and being able to put a face to the name
if you're joining for the first time i
see in the chat already that a few
people are welcome to the hangout
i'm rachel and it's great to meet you
if this is your first hangout
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's
really going on in the world of data
science
and the sessions are all recorded and
shared to the rstudio youtube
as well as the data science hangout site
so you can always go back and re-watch
or
find helpful resources there too
i'll add up
up here first that we do also have a
linkedin group for the hangout so if you
do ever want to continue a conversation
you can go there as well tyler or hannah
can share it in the chat for me too
together we're all
here and dedicated to providing an
inclusive and open environment for
everyone
we love when everybody can participate
and we can hear from everyone so there's
three ways that you can ask questions
today
if this is your first time
so you can jump in by raising your hand
on zoom you can put questions in the
zoom chat
and just put a little star
next to your question if you want me to
read it out loud instead
if you're maybe
in like a
loud coffee shop or your dog's barking
or something
and then third we also have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too
and i see tyler just shared that right
as i said it
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience or industry
that you work in as well
but today i'm so excited to be back with
you all and to be joined by my co-host
who i just got to meet la in person last
week lindsay deeds stress testing
production function lead at the federal
reserve bank of minneapolis
and lindsay i'd love to turn it over to
you and have you introduce yourself and
maybe share a little bit about the work
that you do
sure thanks rachel uh rachel i think we
actually maybe met
in 2020 but i know no one remembers the
time before the pandemic uh yes
in san fran in san fran possibly um but
no really appreciate uh all of the help
that you've provided in helping to share
some of our open postings and all that
in the last year and was great to meet
you in person as well as well as many of
the other folks who've done data science
hangouts uh over the past
year
so i'm lindsay dietz i
am currently essentially a data science
quant manager within the federal reserve
bank of minneapolis
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the federal reserve system although
i'm guessing a lot of you have heard
things about our chairman jay powell
basically the federal reserve system is
13 separate entities so there's a board
of governors
at in washington dc um which was nice a
lot of them i got to see a lot of
colleagues at the conference last week
as well
and then there are 12 separate
individual reserve banks so
i'm in the one in minneapolis which
covers the ninth district um although
the work that i do is very national in
nature
i work on what's called the large bank
stress test um
which essentially is a
a way to see how banks would
would do under a severe recessionary
situation so we have
a set of internal models that we use to
sort of assess their performance
and look at outcomes of that test and is
published
on an annual basis uh except for in 2020
which we got to do it twice there are
two publications from that year which
i'm sure all of you can relate to having
maybe twice as much work in 2020
even even though things had changed a
lot
um so my background is that i
uh
have a sort of math stats upbringing
undergrad and a little bit of grad
school and then started work in finance
um
decided that i wanted to be a professor
so i went back for a phd in statistics
about halfway through i realized you
know what i'm really enjoying the most
is sort of the consulting
aspects of of the work
um and that you know i get to apply all
these like statistical concepts in
different fields
and for me that you know most
interesting space was was finance and
economics at the time and so um i had
some connections with federal reserve
bank of minneapolis is a really great
fit as sort of a
you know research institution but also a
place where i could um
do this kind of applied statistics work
that i was interested in
so i had joined a group that does
something called validation which is
basically looking at financial models in
sort of a
way that sort of a journal reviewer
would look at a journal article
submitted
um like what you know have they met the
assumptions of the methods that they're
looking at have they implemented things
correctly are there you know holes sort
of in the logic
so i worked in that space for about
three years
and then about three years ago i
switched over
to this implementation
and analytics work
which essentially looks like
putting our models into code
production quality code
and then developing
analytics to tell stories around the
outcomes or the data
so that our policymakers can make good
decisions and and have um you know sort
of useful
economic stories to tell around the
outcomes of the the stress testing
exercise
so that is a little bit about myself
right now i have a sort of jointly
managing a team of about 12
quants data scientists
that work across all these different
financial models
our program is about 150 people in total
so i get to work very cross-functionally
with a lot of different people with
different skill sets um it's definitely
very interesting and uh in line with the
idea of the consulting work that i
really set out to do
that's great thanks lindsay
um as we wait for questions to come in
from everyone i'm curious what's
something that you're most excited about
right now with regards to data science
yeah i think um so
as a statistician by training we can be
a little bit down on the machine
learning commun community because
sometimes we can say like hey they they
can't explain their results or their
results might be biased in some way so
i'm really
very interested in the movement towards
like the explainable ml
while it's not really something i work
with necessarily on a daily basis i
think it's really going to change
you know
i guess at least the rigor that we think
about going into the data processing and
and how these
um you know seemingly kind of innocuous
argue like our algorithms impact people
in disparate ways and so i have um some
colleagues from grad school who do a lot
of work in this space and very
interested to see where that part of the
field goes um
i think there are a lot of uh you know
useful crossovers for the statistician
and machine learning community
and don't want to be a gatekeeper so i
think
i'm very interested to see where that
goes and and learn more about it
awesome i see a few questions are coming
through on slido already
and someone had asked am i understanding
correctly that models are used to
forecast unique situations like a severe
recession
and if these are so uncommon how is that
done
sure so uh i should have maybe given a
broader explanation so essentially the
federal reserve has a group that will
develop these scenarios which basically
consist of
um several variables so you can think of
things like unemployment rate
or treasury yield curves
being part of that set of variables
and they project paths for those that
sort of emulate what a severe recession
would look like
and then the idea is that we publish
those so those are published typically
around february each year
and then we run our models using those
as sort of the the predictor
variables that that sort of relate to
these different financial
profiles um and banks do the same they
have their own internal sets of models
that that they use as well
so that's how it's done we actually do
publish
what we call a methodology disclosure
again that comes out annually
around the march time frame so i can
send some links to rachel after this to
share with the group as well
yeah definitely and i can share those in
the linkedin group too with
the summary of the session
but i see somebody else had asked
lindsey do you have any tips for
communicating technical results to
non-technical audiences
and by non-technical meaning like
non-coding or non-statistician
yeah
so i would say it's probably key to
think of pretty much every audience as a
non-technical audience even when you
have people who are technical it's best
not to assume that they ever know the
things that you know because you know
it's unlikely that anyone will be as
deeply immersed in a problem as you are
and
in some sense it can almost be worse if
you have a technical person and you're
like why don't you understand this
because then they may you know may feel
a little bit hurt by that but
i would say
it can be hard but the biggest thing is
focusing on the impact of the output
first
so i like to tell my team that
uh you know people what you might think
is like a smallest piece of work is is
something that someone else is gonna
think is sort of magic like uh
just telling someone earlier today
you know they were talking about all the
coding stuff they had done and i'm like
you know the thing that's going to
really impress people is that you just
generated this automated piece of
documentation from your code basically
for free it took you
five minutes
um but that's like the magic piece um i
remember someone at the r studio
conference talking about like minimizing
time to magic um and and that kind of
thing is what really is like the impact
driver for most people so really
focusing on the impact
in
you know regular words removing the
jargon that kind of thing and then you
know trusting yourself that you've done
all the checking the assumptions the
really technical details and you know
writing that down for yourself and
having you know maybe a good appendix or
a technical paper to go with your work
but um
really that is the key i think for for
the non-technical audiences and then
uh sometimes having the
you know people that are non-technical
will ask you questions that you just
didn't even think about
um that that are really very helpful in
sort of being proactive in future
analysis so i would say look at as an
opportunity to like
practice your translation skills even if
it's you know they're not going to
understand your world you're not
necessarily going to understand theirs
but especially for decision makers
managers
you know
bottom lines are important right how
does this how does this save us time how
does this save us money
those are kind of key concepts that i
would would keep in mind for
non-technical spaces
i love that minimizing time to magic
term and i see rob and zach both just
said that in the chat as well i wish i
could give credit to them yeah i wish i
could give credit to who said it but
someone at the conference said that um
in one of the talks so i'll try to find
that after this too
that's great
as someone else asked uh on slido how
has your work been impacted by this
period of high inflation
yeah it's a good question um i will say
that my work is not really in the sort
of inflation interest rate space um but
we're certainly all thinking about it in
the background about how um how we
should be incorporating this or thinking
about the
the data that we're gonna we get in from
from banks when we look at that um
certainly it will change
um things about the the um portfolios
that the banks have
um you know they may be taking certain
actions because of of high inflation
so that's definitely something that
you know we're considering but again i
don't work specifically on inflation
i think i'm trusting that the
federal open market committee and their
tool set will hopefully be able to to
help us in the long run but um
yeah leave that to the
mostly the bank presidents and the board
of governors to to work on um but yeah
just
uh it's definitely you know informing
some of our perspectives as we look at
the data and the outcomes of our models
thank you i see there's a few questions
coming into the chat as well
lisa would you want to jump in and ask
that
hi lindsay hi
lindsay and i are just across the river
from each other so
um yeah i'm just curious um how you got
buy-in at the fed for using our r studio
if you
were the one to
push for those if they're already there
um and then if you've had any luck
getting some
i i don't even like this term i use less
technical people but maybe people who in
the past have used like a lot of super
complicated excel spreadsheets for
example to
try using r
yeah i think um luckily i didn't have to
do too much of the hard work uh up front
but i think
there were a lot of
key kind of decision makers at the
beginning who had some affinity for
actually maybe s plus
even like weren't necessarily using r
but um you know they knew that r was
sort of
blooming a little bit at the time from
you know r has been around for a while i
i should have mentioned i've been an r
user
technically probably for 20 years but
really just in the last five do i feel
like i really
fully understand or not even fully
understand but fully i'm taking
advantage of some of the capacities of r
based on you know like what i learned in
grad school it's almost like i didn't
learn anything
uh so i think uh also it was like pretty
cool to be doing a phd at the time when
like hadley and yue were coming out with
all of these like inventions you know
sort of like the
the knit our framework and the
like um
reshape to d plier kind of framework
um but i think
you know
what was nice about the the place that
we were in was it wasn't necessarily
people using excel but more just like
people using
other
statistical software packages
and i think for for our work um
we needed to
really centralize and unify
like so that we could standardize code
and we could all run each other's code
so we couldn't choose you know multiple
different languages necessarily to do
that
and i think uh you know we had some
smart leaders who sort of saw that open
source was a good way to to move um so
we use
they chose r and then we also used some
python in our our work as well
certainly there is still like a
continuous
buy-in um
work to be done i think people still
uh
you know people are very beholden to the
software that they used in grad school
or undergrad or you know what they've
been using in prior jobs so convincing
so most people who are using more of the
proprietary software
especially like it's economics there are
really specific software packages that
people enjoy using
but uh
you know r is
r is great that it's very approachable
it has a great like it's fairly easy to
google you can get some really old
results if you're not careful but
part of the learning to google process
and i think just having all these
communities um like i said my a lot of
my team was able to go to our studio
conference
you know there's not necessarily
equivalent stuff
for for some of the other software
packages
and i think just being open to really
teaching people the ropes and that uh
you know it's kind of like
being a professor or you just have to
stay a little bit ahead of the students
so i like you know some of the work to
try to turn things into packages within
our framework i'll go run and do a
little bit and then i've had a lot of
success getting our interns to work on
you know to sort of front run some of
this so that we have a like a framework
to give our team um has been very
helpful but
i think uh
you know people are pretty open to just
using the tools that make the most sense
and
it's
it's nice to have the access to the
packages and all of the code in them
just in case there are things that we
need to modify for some reason for our
purposes and
um definitely the open source framework
makes it a lot easier for us to to
utilize a lot of those tools
great night i see there's a bunch of
questions coming in both sido and ian in
the chat
um but zach i see you asked a question
and also if people feel comfortable
introducing yourselves i know it's been
a long time since well a month since
we've all been together
but zach do you want to jump in
yeah
hi everyone uh my name is zach garland
um i am super jealous that everyone
has our studio comp stories um i
couldn't make it this year i do see that
it's supposed to be in disneyland next
year so um i i would definitely like to
be there and i'll probably try my uh
very very hardest to be there um
i feel like it would be like a super fun
place because then you got amusement
parks and code and um that's all good
stuff um but anyways i i
i work with the economics institute and
so it's very related um in ways to
things that you focus on i was curious
what are some of the most interesting
data trends that are new or anomalies
that happened after covet
sure
so i should have said this at the
beginning but i'll say it now that these
are all my views and do not reflect the
views of my federal reserve bank of
minneapolis or federal reserve system
but um i think uh
you know definitely one thing that was
was has been very interesting about this
time that makes it sort of different
from the maybe 2008 to 2010 financial
crisis which a lot of people probably
remember
um was was there was just like an
unprecedented amount of government
support in this
covid time frame
uh you know although maybe it didn't
always feel like it was it was
definitely more than you know sort of
what came through in the
um the great financial crisis of of the
you know late 2000s um and so i think
uh
you know there's kind of a debate about
um you know has the financial industry
how the financial industry sort of may
be benefited from that would they been
you know in the same position without
that sort of government supports even
though it went directly to
you know consumers or you know
individual americans
um
you know a lot of the behavior of people
during
during that time was you know either
they had to use it right away or they
had to put it back and they just put it
back in their deposit account basically
and so that that's been very interesting
people have have referred to
the coveted time frame in some ways as
like a k-shaped recession where some
people
really weren't that affected and others
were just really drastically affected
so i think that
that kind of
mechanic is is very interesting
and also just like the
you know
maybe the co-movement of different
macroeconomic variables that had been
observed and maybe more traditional
recessions were just
not necessarily the same
during this coveted time frame so i
think
you know there's a lot of
supply chain issues that are affecting
things and maybe changing the price
structures that we wouldn't have seen in
other kinds of recessions
so for example people may have noticed
like
the used car market is
is kind of
been sort of insane um i think i could
sell my car back to the dealer six years
later and they would give me maybe more
than i paid for it
um you know partially just because
supplies have been so short um in nature
but um yeah i think there's just a lot
of very different things going into uh
you know how banks are reacting
certainly they're you know some of the
government programs um the banks had to
help with with
the funding and um like the ppp program
paycheck protection program
um so that that resulted in some
interesting data which
like i can't say too much specifically
about the data but um yeah those are
maybe some um
interesting uh anomalies that i've seen
awesome thank you
thanks lindsay
um i see sam asked a question um is your
team using shiny today
we do use shiny um so actually i have a
an interesting story about how we
started using shiny so i think
uh
in about
you know in 2020 when we're you know all
working from home and we're sort of
running running a crazy amount of stuff
um just to better understand you know
the early impacts of the
um
the covid pandemic basically because our
our time frame when we really run the
stress test is is basically april
through june
and so
you know the lockdown period really
occurred essentially in march um and i
don't know that any of us really
expected it to be what it became but
we knew that
we'd need to maybe do more analysis than
normal given the situation
and i think a lot of us
you know there were tools in this case
in excel in other um in other spaces uh
for these sort of key analytics and
um a group of us we're just like
we just can't deal with this we can't we
can't like make constant updates to
these excel spreadsheets
and so basically we got
kind of a little bit of white space for
a couple weeks and i think three or four
of us just sat down and said
let's just try to build these things out
shiny tools
we had we had some access to
um deployment in our studio connect and
so we're like let's just try this out
um and also like we built out uh some
frameworks using just like html
reporting from our markdown
and
you know we put together what's probably
the basis of the set of analytics that
that we still utilize
and so some of those are shiny some of
those are
still in html from our markdown files
but
you know like i think there was a talk
actually in 2020 that inspired me
um to do the
shift things to html and then like that
the next step is very easy to convert
something like that to shiny once you
sort of have the framework laid out in
our markdown
and so there are
um it's actually something we have an
intern working on right now
is to convert some things that are sort
of html into shiny so
we we are able to use shiny we're not
able to convince everyone to use shiny
um but and we're not we're not trying to
be too specific with folks who who
haven't maybe taken
the time to to get used to the shiny
syntax so we're supportive of
other tools tableau et cetera
that people want to use for these sort
of analytics but uh i think our team is
especially those who went to our studio
are very excited about shiny um and even
even those that are outside our team we
told them about shiny for python and
they're they're pretty jacked about that
too
thank you
i um
because you just mentioned your intern
working on that shiny app too i see mike
you had a question question on
the interns working there do you want to
jump in
oh yeah um nice to see you i'm mike
smith at pfizer um
i was just interested to know
how are you
seeing interns at the minute um you know
how are they coming in what are their
levels of
knowledge on python and r and data
science tooling
um i i guess
my feeling is that there would be a
whole lot smarter than they were five
years ago or
10 years ago
maybe uh or at least
uh
yeah so we we have had some great luck
with interns um we
we've had a program in the last couple
years up in minneapolis where we do
graduate students
we call it a data science internship
and their skills have have been pretty
fantastic i mean in some cases you know
they're
even more cutting edge with uh with
these r tools or python tools than we
are ourselves as you know folks who
maybe haven't been in school for a
little while or um haven't had as much
of the dedicated time to study so
like i said it it's been
very easy to set them off doing things
like hey go build go work on building
the shiny app or
um paid like why don't we figure out how
to turn this into a package like let's
work out what is the right uh
you know what is the minimum
documentation we want to put in this um
and sort of developing like how do we
actually build this in the in the
framework that we have or deploy it and
the framework that we have
uh so they've been great and i i mean we
we do
in our interview process you know we do
have sort of a code sample
just to make sure that it you know does
appear that there is uh some skill in
that area but we do also you know we're
pretty open because like the idea is for
them to learn on the job as well
um but i think
all of the interns that i've worked with
have all had uh
very good r skills and i think um at
least some python skills too we've just
been maybe prioritizing the r skills a
little bit more in our in our pool
thanks
that seems to matter what i'm saying is
there's a lot of
uh
it's almost like the interns could teach
us a lot you know yes
no we do we make them do that actually
too
so
there was an anonymous question for at
the beginning which actually ties in to
this as well but when you have people
using multiple programming language so
uh python sas
how do you structure the work and who
does what um
and how do they work together
sure
so i think um we have sort of specific
tools that we like to use for specific
purposes
uh so we'll say we use
r is probably our our main language but
the the developers that we work with
they might use any tool so they might
use sas or stata or matlab or
some other tool or even r basically
and so
uh
you know
a lot of us have sort of the
multi-lingual
background where maybe we weren't coders
and sas or stata or something else but
in the process of helping to translate
that code into sort of a production
environment
we definitely learn on the fly
you know how to how to google the right
things for sas or stata or how to
interpret you know what things are
happening
you know because sometimes like the
algorithms aren't the same
when you have to translate something you
have to kind of determine um
you know how much of that do you need to
dig into versus just say like both cons
conceptually these are both the same
thing but sas does it different than r
or something like that
so i think we did have uh
you know team members with some
familiarity in those spaces just for
some who've worked in economics or
finance longer they've definitely not
necessarily always been able to use r as
their first language so
like at my time before joining the fed
i'd used some sass in my
my first job in finance
so i had a decent background there i had
a decent background in some matlab
and especially my work in validation i
got to see all of those things even
though i wasn't necessarily coding in
them regularly
so i think we've sort of highlighted
that
it's useful to be multilingual
but
because that helps you to translate
things um better or to you know design
them better maybe than they were in some
of those you know there are some
limitations to certain languages um
there are limitations to r but uh you
know to understand how it how it works
more efficiently
in each language can be helpful in the
process so
but we do
i think we more or less match people up
more based on maybe their
financial background versus necessarily
their software background
just because we're all translating to r
for the most part and
the python pieces that we have
are a little more general um and and so
we just have a couple folks on our team
who are a bit more expert in python but
they still also
are expert and are as well
thank you and i i just wanted to mention
to everyone too if there's a particular
question you want to like ask a
follow-up on or you want to share
insights into as well feel free to just
raise your hand on on zoom as well
and then i'll just i'll just know that
you want to jump in
but i
i see as well there was a
anonymous question earlier that was how
does your team think about ethics in
your work when it comes to things like
race or ethnicity
yeah that's a good question uh we
you know i will say that we um
thought maybe i'll separate ethics from
sort of maybe the diversity equity
inclusion
um
you know one of our main goals and
especially for me as like a hiring
manager is
to really thoroughly have um have a pool
every time that we have a posting
uh that meets some specific diversity
criteria but also
um
maybe meet some diversity criteria of
like diversity of thought or diversity
of background
versus just maybe like typical metrics
and so
that means that our hiring process can
sometimes take a little bit longer
um but it also means we don't just hire
the first maybe qualified person
um that we we come across in our pool
and i think internally once we have
people into the organization we really
want to retain them and
so a lot of the focus
within our organization are to have
employee resource networks
that cover sort of you know different
intersectional parts of our our
personalities and work lives
um so something for women or you know
allyship for for a lot of different
spaces
and then within my team
it's actually great we have a
we sort of do an internal
team meeting where we'll usually discuss
you know topics that sort of overlap in
this dei space a lot of times from a
research perspective so we've covered
things like i don't know we looked at
like the iceland four day work week
um they had some studies on that not too
long ago or we look at
you know what's it been like to go back
to the office because our our company
has gone back to sort of a hybrid
mode and what would make that more
effective for us and how has that
changed maybe things in in your personal
life um
so i think it's always you know the goal
is that
uh
it's just part of the work um and that
it's not like a separate thing it's not
like we're doing
d and i now and then we go back to our
day job no it's it's meant to be
integrated with within our day job
just to help
you know help everyone realize that
these things are always there
we've also had some really fantastic
anti-racism training and those kinds of
things within our organization
um
but then i think when it comes to
like approaching
the work um like on the you know
modeling side
uh definitely we're considering you know
what's in the data and what's missing
from the data right no data is perfect
um you know we're we're relying on uh
banks to provide data that we ask them
for based on certain instructions
and so understanding you know what's
missing from that data is is really
critical to thinking about
you know sort of like
um dni issues
um
and then uh you know from an ethics
standpoint more just like the
the fed has a very high code of ethics
um there are some very specific things
that we're required um to avoid or uh
comply with and i think uh definitely
some things about you know trading
stocks and
um even cryptocurrency for some folks uh
are
highly restricted um but
i think we do hold ourselves to you know
as high of a standard as we can even
outside of that sort of ethical
code of conduct that we have internally
thanks lindsay
i see jonathan had asked in the chat and
said just for me to read it out loud
but it was what platforms and fun data
set projects did you use to learn or
enhance your r programming skills in
your free time
yeah so i think
um there was a conference
maybe
that i did probably like five years ago
a women in statistics and data science
conference and
that was like the first place i'd
learned about our ladies um and
i think uh
you know
one other person from the minneapolis
area who attended with me uh she was
really inspired and decided to like take
it on and and start up our local chapter
again which had been a little bit
defunct for a while and
i think just going to some of those
meetups is where i was really inspired
to learn like the tidy verse um
you know it's very safe space like it
can i think we had some great
contributors who were able to
give good just really beginner overviews
of some of these topics and then you
know we've had a
pretty consistent um although we've
taken a little bit of a summer break but
pretty consistent talks and
always learned something in our ladies
so that's been a really useful way for
me to do things um
you know just to use those sort of
materials that people put together in in
the course of those kinds of meetups um
yeah i've also
[Music]
enjoyed just like the twitter community
around our stats so i don't always uh
i feel like i kind of know what's going
on even if i don't always like dive into
something but like the the emergence of
this penguins data set
like in every example
um i've been sort of following that uh
recently
and it was even like a highlight of the
sort of open scapes um quarto talk which
i thought was very very cool um
and i think just
you know
trying to immerse myself a little bit
more into the
the community um but
you know sometimes you know if i just
want to learn a package or something
like that i'll just kind of dive into
the page documentation usually people
put pretty good little data examples um
i've also had some good luck uh taking
you know courseras that have good kind
of r examples as the the basis for maybe
learning a new topic
um
but uh yeah it's just great that there's
so much free material you know the book
down
package has made it possible that almost
everyone publishes their books now on um
open source basically if you don't want
to get the hard copy and so i think just
you know copying and pasting from stack
overflow can sometimes be the first step
and he good
learning data analysis project
absolutely and i am i shared some
upcoming our ladies meetups and then our
user groups in the chat as well and when
you sort through them like that on
meetup you can see all of them all over
the world
um but i also wanted to ask everybody in
the chat too on that topic of like i
know you mentioned the penguin data set
but does anybody have like certain data
sets that you use for
like business examples like if you were
making the case to
your leadership
i've been looking for just like
good play data sets that are like a real
business example
if you wouldn't mind sharing those in
the chat that would be awesome
um i see there are
lots of other
questions from earlier let me go up here
um actually michael you had your hand
raised do you want to jump in
sure i can jump in hi lindsey
i'm at the data science consulting firm
catch brook analytics and we work with a
ton of banks and lending institutions so
this is really right up my alley i
appreciate you uh coming on here today
my question for you was with stress
testing in particular which is an area
that we work
in quite a bit in developing those
models
having some trouble lately with the uh
sort of new approaches that we have and
new tools that we have for bayesian
modeling that allow us to give more of a
probabilistic output which sort of feels
more like a stress testing e uh type
type place to to have those models as
opposed to deterministic models that
just say hey this is exactly what's
going to happen next year here's your
point estimate
um
i've had mixed
experience sort of getting buy-in for
bayesian models i don't know if you use
any bayesian methods in
your work at all and if so
do you have any words of wisdom for
getting buy-in on those
yes i would say i don't use any
specifically right now but uh
what i like to say maybe as a selling
point for bayesian models that maybe
people don't think about because um you
know a lot of people are used to
frequentist or likelihood or just maybe
haven't had a course in bayesian
approaches
and this is something that my partner
told me once is that bayesians are just
much more explicit about the assumptions
that are present in their models
so
sometimes i think we think we're getting
things for free when we fit
frequent to style models or likelihood
based methods
and people can be uncomfortable with the
idea of like oh the prior changed and
therefore the output changed
um
and i think uh
i actually think like the you know
credible intervals being like an actual
probability having an actual
probabilistic interpretation is
uh much stronger than sort of the idea
of confidence intervals but a lot of
people just don't
they don't understand maybe the subtle
differences
so i think
uh
you know
what what also people could be afraid of
in bayesian models sometimes is the
you know how long does it take to
actually run this kind of situation
which i think there are a lot of tools
now that you know
can allow you to take you know much
shorter paths to get to an answer
but i would just say that like
it
maybe can be great in certain cases like
where you have very little data um and
you really have to make an assumption
right
um so i like to
i don't know i think i like to think
about like maybe hr cases where you're
trying to determine are we meeting sort
of
our diversity goals but there are only
like five people
in this group right can we really make a
good assessment using like a frequentist
analysis to say like well one one out of
the five people
um you know so we're at 20
but
um in that case it could be useful to
think about like well what's a bayesian
approach to this which is that like
maybe we make some assumption
that we're either hitting our criteria
or not hitting our criteria and then let
the data do a little bit of of informing
of that
you know updating of that assumption
um you know i think if you have you have
a huge amount of data uh
you know theory says that the
basically the
bayesian approach and the likelihood
approach are essentially the same
um in those cases uh so that's maybe not
the case where you'd want to make your
sort of argument but certainly in the
small data cases or
um
i think there are definitely tools for
different kinds of time series or
been reading a little bit about this
like google time series method um that
relies on bayesian stuff or basing like
you know model selection criterions um
that you know there's definitely ways to
make arguments about perhaps how much
better those methods do just from a
prediction performance so maybe it's
more to about like what are the metrics
people really care about
and can you hit those better with the
bayesian model than perhaps like a
frequentist model
awesome i appreciate it thank you
do you have any recommendations
uh what doesn't work
shiny has helped quite a bit uh you know
building a shiny app that shows those
probabilistic simulations teaching
people what a histogram is is is a good
place to start for me and that's uh you
know
most of the population does not know
what a histogram is even a lot of people
that i work with in risk management
which is uh
interesting but um yeah no i would say
that the places you made great points
about when it might be appropriate and
when it not when it isn't appropriate
and obviously if you have plenty of data
you know you shouldn't need to employ a
beijing model but we see some portions
of credit portfolios
some segments of those portfolios that
have never had a default event so if
someone's trying to predict probability
of default
take a frequent approach it's going to
be zero but there's not there's not
really a zero percent chance that you
know no loan in that segment of the
portfolio will ever default so that's
that's sort of where i think priors can
help quite a bit
definitely
thanks michael
brian i see you have your hand raised
and i think it might be for this topic
too you want to jump in
yeah sure um
so there is a whole new
world coming out for stress testing
called cecil which is a probabilistic
method so right now it's
semi-deterministic where they come up
with scenarios and you have to model out
okay inflation goes to this unemployment
goes to that blah blah blah model your
portfolio spit it out
i worked on solvency ii which is an
european version of it far more i'll say
far more sophisticated advanced because
it's 100 stochastic
so in the insurance industry it's all
bayesian type you say
our
portfolio of losses
is a log normal distribution with these
parameters here is the fit that proves
it out and then you begin to do all
sorts of stochastic sampling and
everything else
um i also worked in the area of natural
catastrophe risk where
you're looking at you know a magnitude 9
earthquake hasn't happened yet but we
know it will and what is the probability
of it and what does that distribution
look like and you get into extreme value
theory um
so short answer
it's kind of it's coming down the pipe
for banking because of the switching
framework
um insurance industry has been doing it
10 to 15 years you could almost say 20
if you go back to the early days of the
uk
um when i worked over there so um lots
of opportunity lots of opportunity to
harness something like the power of r
where you can generate
hundreds of thousands of simulations in
in seconds um versus i'll say 20 years
ago people were doing that in excel
and they're lucky if they got through it
thanks fred
let me jump over to
mike i see you asked a question around
packages and
federica you asked you also asked about
what packages are you used
um
so lindsay would love to hear what are
some of your favorite packages that are
used and mike asked specifically how do
you utilize the fred r
package
yeah so
uh
favorite packages um
so i said this in a twitter thread so
i'll repeat it here stats obviously
we're part of the stats as part of the
base load
of r uh very important um
but uh kidding aside so d plier um very
important for you know
i think a lot of the work we're doing is
data processing
um to get you know before we get to the
modeling part um so deep fire
uh
you know still
work a lot you know visualization gg
plot 2 and then
sometimes adding plotly to gg plot 2 or
have
tried out a little bit with high charter
which is pretty neat as well for sort of
the interactive visualization
um
i
uh
i don't know where it's gone but i think
it's still out there the the dt plier
package um i really liked as a having
sort of the interface d plier kind of
interface to the data table package
because i have a hard time with the
data table syntax just on my own um but
i liked having that interface and used
that before as well just to
make handling some of the big data
a little bit easier
um
let's see what other common ones uh well
certainly shiny and are markdown
for some of the reporting tools
uh
see if there's anything new and fancy
that i've tried out
i mean i think after the rstudio
conference everyone really wants to
try out cordo we're trying to get some
installs of the the newer
version of our studio to to try some of
that stuff out
um
you know it's a little bit challenging
sometimes when you don't have admin
rights to your computer to do some of
these things but i think a lot of us
have downloaded on our home computer
and tried them out
um
yeah i would say those are sort of
boring boring answers and i don't have
anything maybe revolutionary because
probably a lot of people on this call
use some of those similar packages for
their everyday life but i mean deep fire
is just
sort of game changing um you know i
don't i don't really know sql very well
because i just
select all and then do the processing in
r basically um when i when i have access
to a package like deepwire so um that's
been been really helpful
awesome thank you
there was a question sorry i didn't
answer the second part sorry the fred
somebody asked
um so uh so fred is this big
like
open source data endeavor by um federal
reserve bank of st louis but is a very
common source for a lot of economics
data
uh
they do have like an api
and i think um i think there are
actually multiple r packages that can
connect
to that um
some of it is a little bit uh weird you
kind of have to have these string ids
that uh connect you to a certain data
series but i've used i haven't used fred
r too much in in work but i've used it
as sort of like presentation
um so fred r has uh like a reasonable
interface to get
get data from fred um then there are
just
thousands of economic time series on
that page
you know multiple measures of inflation
or unemployment rate or like all of the
common ones that um you might be
interested in sort of matching up with
perhaps other kinds of data um so that's
a very comprehensive set of data
i assume the bureau of labor statistics
may have something
similar but i have not i'm guessing
there might be a blsr kind of package
somewhere floating out there but i
haven't tried that but i think those are
maybe
two good sources for like
government style statistics
great thank you
yeah and if other other people have
packages to share feel free to put them
in the chat too oh thanks ben i think
that's the bls package
perfect
there is a question earlier and i might
need help with some of the acronyms here
but it
is for monte carlo based simulation for
var stress testing
do you predominantly use stan
or also use newer
ppl which i just asked is probabilistic
programming language
tools for your production grade code
so i can read that again
or you got it
yeah yeah i got it um
i think the var here is probably meaning
value at risk um
so
i would say we
you know i probably can't get into too
much detail but you know we
we use r um if we need to do a
simulation we
code that up um appropriately as i said
we don't really use beesian models
um at this point uh but
like i said uh i can i can share the
link to essentially our methodology
document which tells you a little bit
about
you know the functional forms that are
in the models um that are done
uh
but you know as people sort of noted
like
their estimation components and then the
scenario component is essentially
deterministic in that there is a
specific scenario that runs through the
model
and produces a set of sort of
projections
over a certain horizon
so
yeah i don't i don't know what the ppl
tools are so i would be interested to
know uh if anyone wants to volunteer
like what those tools might look like
any takers
feel free to put in the chat too
yeah robert would love to explain it
um
let's see
so
i know we're getting to the top of the
hour i want to make sure i haven't
missed
questions in here
um
i see june you had asked a question with
a little star next to it so i'll read it
could you tell us what are the key
variables that banks report for your
stress assessment
sure so
there are
again this is public information so i'm
not giving away any secrets
there are instructions that we put out
to the world um although i don't know
that many people would read them outside
of bankers or maybe consultants that
work with bankers um they're they're a
long read
that uh so it covers just a number of
characteristics about their portfolio
so for stress testing specifically
there are some data sets that are
required on a monthly basis
so those are like loan level portfolios
so you can think of like credit card
portfolio or
mortgage portfolio
there's data that's required quarterly
so that includes you know
a lot of other information information
on their trading book
or counterparties or
something called operational risk losses
and also things like wholesale losses
or wholesale portfolios
and then uh there's annual data that is
really specific for the stress test um
that's run annually so information about
like their capital planning you know how
they plan to distribute things
so that data is all very
uh confidential um however if you're
really interested in knowing more about
sort of the banking
portfolios there is a data set that's
widely used and is is very
um very good it's called the fr y99c
which doesn't mean a lot without context
but uh
it essentially has like high level
information
quarterly about um the bank's operations
so their revenues their balances
um you know sort of their expenses all
of those kinds of things actually if you
looked at like
like a quarterly earnings page for a
bank you would probably find a link to
their y9c submission
because that is public information
i don't know if anyone has built
an api um definitely there are sites
that have pdfs or excel documents of
these these things but i can send a link
to the or i'll just type that it's
called the fry99c
in the chat in case any of you want to
look it up um
can be a very good sort of
uh top-down way to look at you know
maybe the differences and and better
understand like where different kinds of
banks are are making their markets
great thank you
um i just want to say if there are a lot
of questions so if anybody has a
question that wasn't asked yet and you
want to raise your hand on zoom so that
i know i can call on you
next book one that was
asked earlier is something that comes up
a lot is the benefit of advanced
education or phds in industry
do you feel it was beneficial to go back
to grad school
it was beneficial but not in the way
that i had intended it to be which like
i said at the very beginning uh
my thought was i want to be a professor
and this is the only way to do that um
i think
there are probably other ways i could
have gotten to this stage in my career
and i would say
definitely going to grad school is not
recommended for the faint of heart
or it's not like a thing to do when you
don't know what to do because you
definitely should be be confident that
you you want to do it
but i think sometimes like the
the things that have really benefited me
from especially doing a phd are
uh you know learning how to think
learning how to connect like really high
level concepts like i don't know every
tool in the sort of econometrics tool
kit
but um having learned some very general
ways to think about modeling and
statistics help me zoom in much quicker
when i need to learn those kinds of
things
and i think just
you know there's a lot of opportunities
to talk about research both in a very
technical way but then also in a pretty
non-technical way
and working on like your presentation
skills in that way
i will say like i didn't learn that much
about being a manager or being a leader
in grad school
and those are things that i've had to
rely on other life experiences to teach
me and and work on
directly so
i just want to
you know not give that implication that
if you go get a phd you become a manager
um definitely those are sort of separate
skill sets for the most part but
uh you know working
in in working in real life kind of
outside of grad school
i think a lot of the skills have been
transferable just learning how to solve
problems in general is um is a skill
that's very transferable and i think
sometimes maybe i have too much of a
logical view of the world
like because of
you know grad school or uh luckily i
have a very nerdy partner and we can
exchange statistics jokes um or talk
about
probability spaces with measure zero
and understand what we're what each of
us means but
um yeah i mean i think
i think i wouldn't i wouldn't have not
done it uh look in sort of the counter
factual case um but there are multiple
ways to get you know to achieve this
path and you know not even going to grad
school works for some for a lot of
people
just because of all the tools we have
available
super helpful thank you
i know we just hit the top of the hour
so if you have to run to a meeting i
don't want to hold you
from that
do you have time for one more question
uh one more question is fine yep okay
um javier i see you had a follow-up
question to
the bayesian conversation do you want to
jump in
yeah thanks um and i joined late so
apologies if you already covered this
lindsay but um
i used to work with a lot of like phd
statisticians and actuaries that were
very fond of
sort of the core stand packages for
bayesian modeling um
and i know that over the last few years
tidy models has really kind of you know
allowed you to tap into those engines
and whatnot i'm just curious if in
practice
you
have kind of you know started to take on
more of the tidy models approach tapping
into those bayesian engines and algos or
if you're still using sort of the
you know core standalone framework like
rstan or stan arm or something like that
yeah so we we don't have uh
like
bayesian frameworks in in the space that
i'm in
i think
people though are learning about tidy
models and how we can apply those i
think certainly people were inspired by
the
um you know the idea of like recipes and
those kinds of things that come with
kind of the tidy models framework um but
right now i mean
i think i've used our stand a little bit
in my maybe dissertation work but i have
not um and would be very interested to
know that there are i am interested to
know that there are
newer better frameworks than sort of the
old stuff because i it it is definitely
an intellectual curiosity for me as well
to work in that like new like our stand
framework i don't know if my
professors would be okay with it but
no sometimes they're a little bit purist
on the mcmc methods but versus the stand
method but some of us have to get the
work done in a timely fashion
so appreciate you bringing it
up thank you
awesome well thank you so much lindsay
for joining us today i don't want to
keep you too long over i really
appreciate your time and sharing your
insights with us
if people do want to hang out
we'll be here just hanging out and
staying on for a little bit longer um
but thank you so much lindsay
i think lindsay had to
drop right away but
she shared earlier that the best way to
stay in touch is through linkedin so i
shared lindsay's linkedin through the
chat as well
but any other general questions hey lisa
thank you
but if anyone has other general
questions for the group um
and you want to stay on and hang out for
a few more minutes feel free to to ask
them
or raise your hand
i know there were a few that i may have
missed unfortunately
i see marcos you have your hand raised
you want to jump in
yeah my first time here it was really
cool hearing i didn't do anything about
beijing modeling or uh much about uh
stress testing and financial stuff but
it was still really cool but i'm just
curious like since this it feels like a
really our centric group i'm just
curious like show of hands or
i guess you can't do a show of hands
show of
something in the chat like
in terms of like i started with r i
taught myself shiny i did a bunch of r
stuff but then my job when i finally
became a data scientist was all python
so i'm just curious like
what the mix is of the hangout like do
we feel like we're 80 are like 50 50.
like people use both just curious what
the
the tool breakdown is but regardless
great questions and this is a point i
made to some colleagues i i was
virtually attended the r conference and
all the other people seem really cool so
even though i'm a python person like i
want to be friends with all of you so
i love it
yeah that's that's a great question um
want to use the chat window or people
feel free to to jump into
sounds like a lot of
python curious our 50 50.
and marcos thanks for for joining
welcome
did you find out about the
conference uh your talk uh cause i
watched your talk at our studio and uh
and i i thought there's a data science
hangout actually i might have been on
the discord i was like what's data
science hang out um i think it was a
discord four-year talk
um that's great thank you thanks for
coming to me talk i think one of my
colleagues might join at some point
another uh data scientist over at carmix
my comment i
shared the word at my at work as well
that's great
thank you if anybody wants to share it
with colleagues um i just put the
the short link to add it to your
calendar too
thank you all so much for joining any
other general questions for the group or
does anyone want to jump in and give
some feedback to marketers as well
marco's a question actually
i'm just curious marcos um
when you're well in in your specific
role or your team's function are
are you all working more on back end
type work or are you regularly teaming
with stakeholders and sort of like
communicating data insights and you know
dashboards or something like that it's
it's the data flows up but usually not
directly like like so i work in core i
work in pricing systems so we're like on
the team that
go to carmix.com and sell your car like
you're gonna get an offer on your car no
surprise there's algorithms behind that
um that's what my team does uh so it's
mostly it is integrated in terms of like
some productionization and the actual
machine learning but um
we're not really building a lot there
are people on my team that do like
reports on like profitability or
whatever but that's not really
um my function i focus more on the
algorithms and the
systems but happy to touch base um
if you want to learn more
thanks thanks
well thank you all so much for joining
if i don't want to feel like you have to
stay around if you're getting ready to
leave but if you do want to stay around
and hang out
feel free to just keep jumping in and
asking questions or
connecting with each other but thank you
all so much for joining
thanks rachel
ryan said he's happy to answer any
stress testing questions
so we'll put you on the spot bran
sure i was a professional
model validator independently in the uk
for stress testing so
if anybody has any questions on that i
wrote
papers and documents to push back
against the central bank england and the
central bank ireland who were regulators
at the time so
um
[Music]
and studied a lot of the banking c car
it's not that different
i'm trying to double check if there were
any questions on that that i missed from
earlier too
did everyone else know it was d plier
because i totally been saying dippler my
whole life like i had no idea it was
deep player does that everyone just know
that
it took me a little while
i learned r and then i met python people
and never talked to any other art people
who used dpplier
you know the reason i knew is because of
there's a
hex sticker for it
and it looks like little pliers oh
so then that's how you remember it yeah
that makes total sense i mean it makes
them it's a much better way to pronounce
it just you know
then there's yeah there's a db plier d
plier
yeah
awesome well thank you all for joining
doesn't seem like there's other
questions but
so nice to see you all again um we will
be back here same time same place next
week too
um we'll be joined by adam bly who is
ceo and founder
of system
and if you want to see the upcoming
speaker list it's on the
our studio data science hangout website
too
which i just put there in the chat again
but thanks all
have a great rest of the day
you